oh my
[Music]
god oh my god
man man
man let me tell you something okay man
here's the thing son
son son i know i got a cold right i know
i'm all congested i know i'm all nasally
y'all are gonna have to bear with me
this story is lit okay so here's the
thing man i don't even know if lit's a
word if it's not a word anymore i'm
bringing it back this story was a oh my
gosh amazing all right and we're almost
done this is the second to the last
issue right so we're almost done with
this whole thing but oh my god in heaven
man this is just like one of the best
stories god one of the best stories i've
ever read okay here's the thing in the
last video that we did you basically had
the incredible hulk right he would
essentially let off what was by all
standards of measurement a gamma bomb
and nobody knew the incredible hulk
could let off that much energy at one
time that was equivalent to like
thousands of of gamma bombs detonating
at the same time when the smoke cleared
from that fight between cosmic iron man
and the incredible hulk that basically
you ended up having thor who had become
a hulk and we didn't know exactly how we
do get that explained here we didn't
know exactly how but it's basically
world breaker thor and i love it man i
absolutely love world breaker thor uh
because it gets crazy so as soon as this
happens right like the cosmic suit of
iron man is kind of activated yet again
but any chance this thing had of being
able to defeat or defeat a world breaker
thor ends like that right it in so fast
this guy never had a chance right like
literally the suit just gets torn to
shreds i mean like world breaker thor
just rips it apart now in the midst of
all this with a suit totally added
capacity iron man just getting ready to
die at the hands of thor the hulk steps
in now here's one of the things to know
this is not world breaker hulk all right
this is not world breaker hulk this is
just the incredible hulk right savage
hulk immortal hulk whatever you want to
call them it's basically just you can
kind of call them a little bit above
baseline hulk it's enough that you can
go toe-to-toe with world breaker thor so
i guess maybe it's world breaker hook
but whatever the case is it's literally
just the hulk and thor now the thing
about this is that where iron man
questions as to whether or not this is
banner the response of hulk is no
banner's not here it's just me and so
he's like you need to run you need to
get out of here as fast as you possibly
can because this battle is not meant for
you man you're gonna get incinerated
you're gonna get destroyed in this thing
and so what follows is one of the most
epic fights between the two now here's
the beauty about this thor and the
incredible hulk the fights between the
two over the years it's the stuff of
legend not all not all fights between
the two of them are good and honestly i
would say the stories and the artistic
depictions of the fights between thor
and hulk and the modern era are better
than they were back then the reason why
a lot of the old stories the old fights
between uh thor and hulk are so
i guess maybe uh are put on pedestals by
fans is because of the significance of
the writers at the time and what they
were doing but when you go back and you
look pound for pound right like those
old stories like this story here banner
of war there's there's never been an
instance where the incredible hulk and
thor have fought each other and it was
as good as this i'm sorry you know to
all those old writers out there don't
mean any disrespect to him but it's just
not on the same level right it's
interesting it's it's more intense more
fast-paced because the comics back then
were a reflection of the time and so
comics back in the 70s were usually
slower they were more methodical they're
nowhere near as fast paced and crazy as
they are right now but this fight is
kind of insane now we don't get to see a
lot of it instead what ends up happening
here is the conflict shifts to the
mindscape of the incredible hulk where
you have bruce banner's mind just
sitting out there now remember in the
last video that we covered because
odin's spirit or his essence is in the
hammer of mjolnir when the hammer hit
the incredible hulk it allowed the
essence of odin to transfer from the
hammer into the mind of the incredible
hulk and that's how he's here talking to
bruce spanner but one of the things that
banner says here is that it's not him
running the running the ship anymore
right like the incredible hulk
personality is the dominant personality
now the other thing about this and
what's what's really cool is he
literally tells odin like we're odin's
like you need to get off your ass right
like we've got to find some way to end
this this is cool and it's one of the
things that i love because historically
speaking when it came to banner either
banner absolutely hated the incredible
hulk or banner was kind of afraid of the
incredible hulk there haven't really
been a whole lot of stories where bruce
banner overpowers the incredible hulk in
his own mind then in a lot of ways he's
kind of afraid of what the hulk stands
for or again he outright hates it what
you have here just by virtue of odin's
presence and the fact that he's like
this is not a time for milk stops right
this is a time for men that have some
fortitude and they've got some some
strong knees and some conviction and
they've got some heart that's what this
is for are you a coward or are you a man
and so that's that's like challenging
banner in that way banner's like yes
like like i'm tired of playing second
fiddle to the incredible hulk and i'm
tired of not being in control of my own
mind now it's not donnie kate's just
doing this willy-nilly the reality is
that for decades it's been building up
to this if you go and you read the
incredible hulk mythos over really i
would say since the 90s if we're being
honest with ourselves especially from
the onslaught saga going forward a lot
of it's been banner just exercising more
control and having more confidence in
relation to the incredible hulk or at
least that personality so this has been
building for quite some time it was
never a main focal point of the
incredible hulk storytelling it was
never a major thing that was going on
it's really donnie kate's just kind of
connecting the dots of how different
writers have been sort of crafting their
own incredible hulk stories with regards
to the relation between banner and hulk
himself so it's cool to see this whole
thing happening right it's cool to see
that it's all kind of coming together at
the end of this and so he literally
tells odin like i have a big favor to
ask here right like i've got an enormous
favor to ask now this favor is going to
become very important later on in the
moment we get what's actually one of the
coolest moments i would say probably in
the recent thor stories right in recent
memory when it came to four so the whole
thing behind this is that while this
great big huge fight's happening there
really isn't a whole lot iron man can do
he tries to call for backup but nobody
can hear him right so it's kind of like
okay uh i guess he's kind of out here on
his own then he's met by the ravens now
initially catches him off guard and iron
man's like oh that's right you know thor
he rides around on a chariot pulled by
goats he's got ravens to talk for him
the guy's a beast master like he's the
most in tune with animals anyone's ever
been and no one quite understands why
although i will say tooth nasher is
pretty badass those are guys who don't
know about the goats of thor those guys
are legit man dude dude thor's goats
they're like the most underrated
characters and thor comics nobody ever
gives them enough do like it's just we
need to do a video right beyond omega
level force goats we need to make a
video on that
way to make a video on that because
those guys dude those goats are legit
man i love thor's goats so i almost i
love them almost as much as i love
captain carrot i love captain care
captain carrots is super bunny but what
ends up happening here is when the
ravens start talking to iron man what
you end up getting here is iron man
actually yanked away through the bifrost
of course brought to sif and steph does
this largely because there's no point in
iron man being there he's likely going
to die but she also says we're bringing
thor to asgard right thor's losing his
mind he's going nuts uh obviously he's
not himself but if thor is going to be
brought back down to sanity it's going
to be an asgard it's not going to be
somewhere out in midgard in some space
gladiatorial arena that's not going to
happen and so she summons the bifrost to
bring world breaker thor back to asgard
and he resists now here's the thing the
ability to resist the bifrost is
virtually unheard of right like the
ability to just deny the bifrost
teleporting you somewhere that's almost
unheard of almost everybody who's ever
been summoned by the bifrost is snatched
away usually whenever you see thor
involved with a bifrost odin or somebody
like that they go with it right because
the bifrost is taking them usually to
where they want to be but to quite
literally see world breaker thor resist
the bifrost is nuts even to the point
that the bifrost cannot withstand the
the pull of world breaker thor and the
fact that world record thor won't move
and as a result the bifrost shatters
right world breaker thor breaks the
bifrost now just to give you guys
perspective this is an inter-dimensional
teleportation device this thing will
take you virtually to basically anywhere
in the main marvel universe along with
any of the other dimensions right so it
won't take you to like uh let's say like
the realm of door mama it won't really
take you to like the dark dimension
because it's not connected to the
bifrost but the fact that he literally
shatters it destroys the five frost you
know she's like the bifrost is no more
now at the same time thor is the all
father presumably he can just recreate
it but the fact that he broke it is
absolutely astounding here it's kind of
mind-blowing and even odin himself is
surprised by what's going on now of
course where odin almost kind of gives
up and is like thor's gone like there's
nothing there's nothing to do for him
now like he just has to basically be
destroyed the responsive banner is no i
think i can stop him and when odin
chimes in he's like no like i'm not
aiding you in your quest to lose even
more of that mind of yours we must try
to subdue him with whatever it is that
they can possibly use and the response
of banner and this is really really
important here because it explains how
thor became world breaker thor in the
first place the responsive banner is he
basically says this titan that's inside
of him it possesses people no that's a
cool thing because we already kind of
knew that based on the situation in el
paso but we didn't know how far-reaching
it was we didn't really know exactly how
it worked the result of this is that it
was it's really just thor possessed by
the power of the titan hulk albeit him
being out of world breaker thor form now
what banner's concern here is if you do
not if you do not do what i ask you to
do odin if you do not grant me this
favor the titan hulk is going to
manifest and when that happens it will
be too late there will be no one here
who can stop it no one on that level of
power they can bring it to an end now
the reality is that banners being a
little over dramatic here right like
depending on the circumstances the
cosmic entities might step in but the
reality here is they most likely won't
because what you would end up seeing is
a titan hulk would likely be destroyed
by some force of energy out there that
is not from the cosmic entities but most
everybody they know would be destroyed
in the process right like most all their
friends and family would basically come
to an end like the first targets would
be asgard and earth and then after that
it's basically everything so the
immediate threat is like your world and
mine are going to be obliterated if we
if you do not do what i ask you to do
odin and so it's quite literally banner
saying quit being a punk do what i tell
you to do because if we don't odin i won
i'm smarter than you and if we don't
we're both gonna die now this is cool
man it's cool to see banner just like
challenging odin right and just being
like listen you'll coot you have no idea
what's going on here in this bigger
picture right i mean if you had both
eyes i guess you could probably see the
bigger picture but you can't so do what
i tell you to and so like while world
breaker thor is just losing his mind the
hammer comes flying at him right now he
goes to grab it and it breaks his arm as
it flies right through and so ultimately
like with banner back in control of the
body odin's like you better be sure of
this and the response of of literally
banner is there's only one way to find
out and he takes the hammer like as it
comes flying towards him and he smacks
it on the ground and when that happens
he basically turns into all father hulk
which i gotta say man this is legit like
it's just it's one of the most amazing
moments ever right it's just it's it's
it's ridiculous right like literally the
incredible hulk becomes all father hulk
and he's gonna fight world breaker thor
this story is amazing with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching massive
plush hanger and i will catch you all
later
peace